with them you could say when your CI
Francisco marroquín a que you nurse your
free marketeers I just can't imagine
going to any other school in Guatemala
the first book that I read was economics
in one lesson probably no surprise I
believe in the ideas that the university
is trying to promote I want to help to
change my country ideas are so important
because thoughts become things well the
system under which most of Latin America
has lived since colonial time is what
Adam Smith called mercantilism where the
governments try to run the economy and
they establish privileges protection for
this industry fomenting that other
activity and trying to allocate
resources according to the wisdom of
those and on power at the moment
the result is miss allocation of
resources on very wide scale
most of all Manuela ow he was a founder
of owner CEO Francisco marroquín he was
an engineer by training an entrepreneur
natural entrepreneur but not only
enterpreneur business wise he was also
an amazing intrapreneur of ideas as a
young man I outlet in the US and Canada
eventually earning an engineering degree
from Louisiana State University but when
it comes back to what Amala and he tries
to find a job now an engineer a father
he's Cesar is very difficult to get a
job and he couldn't find an explanation
one of his friends who flies to Mexico
brings back to to Guatemala pamphlet
written by dutiful misses and Musa reads
that and he says well here I can find an
explanation as to why what Amana is
still poor and he took the adventure for
business trip to the States to visit the
friends at foundation for economic
education where he gets to meet Leonard
Reid and the whole bunch he was there
working at at the time this is the late
1950s of course they were all thrilled
to find this young engineer from
Guatemala who was intellectually curious
who was smart as you can get and who you
getting involved in the battle of ideas
eventually also becomes a member of the
Mont Pelerin society where he gets to
meet lots of people and where he started
to have an intellectual relationship
with a Friedrich Hayek and it was a
conversation with Hayek that also
realize the importance of college
education mousou says well this is seen
like a like a sensible strategy if you
have educate the intellectually
eventually the ideas will come down and
turn around the country mousou a yahoo
founded Francisco marroquín University
in 1971
today UFM has around 2700 students and
the school remains committed to the
ideas upon which it was founded I think
one of the things makes that makes us
unique is that all of our students
doesn't matter whether you're studying
architecture education or medicine and
of course law and economics everybody
has to take three courses and
free-market economics and on top of that
everybody has to take two courses and
social philosophy the social philosophy
of freedom so all of our students read
Hayek all our students with Mises when I
started reading Mises I was in Germany
for vacation and people were talking
about the the situation in Germany and
how wages were going down in Germany
because there are all these different
immigrants coming in and nobody really
knew how to interpret the situation
they're just sort of complaining about
what was going on and I was actually
pretty excited because I could
understand well what's happening is that
there are people with lesser
opportunities and now they're getting
greater job opportunities and you know
that's gonna get production costs
lowered which is going to make
everything cheaper and even though
they're complaining right now
everything's gonna get better I think
that students are already more
suspicious of government in Guatemala
because its failures are more apparent a
corruption it's more up front and in
your face but I think that once you give
them the tools to analyze it and to
understand why it happens it's very
helpful and it lends itself to students
of all different backgrounds and also of
different ideological persuasions when
well when students get involved in in
experiment experiment is a great tool
for learning about economics because you
don't learn from the blackboard you
don't learn because you know the teacher
or the professor drew a certain supply
and demand curve but you learn because
you participate actively as a buyer or
seller and you see how your behavior and
the behavior of others conforms to
theory usually or in some cases you know
why doesn't about eight years ago and
you
2003 we decided to do different
experimentations on bringing Socratic
practice to the classroom the students
like Hayek says have knowledge that's
unique to them it's dispersed amongst
all of them so you can make that
intellectual capital alive by offering
environments where students are choosing
where they are interacting where they're
exchanging or you can put them in rooms
like this where they are still silent
and passive what other things are
learning here is learning how to learn
political corruption and socialist
policies have made life extremely
difficult for most Guatemalans can a
small radical free-market University
really make a difference I think what
makes the school really unique is that
it's set in a country that is going
through a really tough situation right
now the people are really concerned
about how to fix their country and they
see these ideas as the solution to that
the commitment that I found here is
absolutely unique what we want to do
here is to continue the conversation on
these ideas and our hope is that the
students our motto King will eventually
become leaders in their own fields as
entrepreneurs and maybe some of them
even politicians and they will be the
ones who will be turning around the
tortilla and what they might I'm
bringing this ideas to life we can plant
an idea in somebody's mind that's so
powerful you FM graduate Alfredo Guzman
was appointed director of the state-run
telecommunications monopolies guat L in
1995 at that time Guatemala had a
population of 11 million people but
fewer than 300,000 phones
against all odds Guzman and his
colleagues privatized wattle and opened
the market to free competition how did
that experiment work out today we have
over 18 million telephone lines in
Guatemala the people that were part of
my team
that work on that most of them came from
the ufm so we had a clear vision of
saying oh we should do these within a an
environment of freedom I think that dr.
Aiyaa was very wise in thinking that it
was important to address ideas and how
ideas change the world people would feel
comfortably what I'm saying
but he in many ways he was that beacon
of light for Latin America some of the
most important influence of the more
parent society has been in other in
countries other than the leading
countries for example in Guatemala where
you were some of the members of the Mont
Pelerin society organized a private
university Francisco marroquín
University which has become one of the
leading universities in Latin America
entirely based on the principles of more
Pelerin society on free markets and
private property it may sound ambitious
and it's ambitious but my hope for for
for Guatemala is if we do our job right
here Martin King we were able to to
teach the intellectual leaders of this
country I hope to see saw like a Hong
Kong in Latin America that's what I'm
hoping for
you